lucky ist people court on camera bei
meiner visage bin ich da glaube ich
nicht dabei er sagt bei seiner rede 2020
weiß nicht so das beste jahr in dem
moment kommt ein blitz andere dienste so
comedy veranstaltungen und sowas dämlich
war sowas schon lustig mich macht was
lustig sprachenlernen delfine sind so
krank
nein diese beiden jungs haben einfach so
random auf der straße gekämpft als
koller mcgregor vorbei gefahren aber der
sde stehen von gestern etwas verlorene
ok gegen mich wird er wahrscheinlich
immer noch alle mal gewinnen mit seinem
kleinen finger blind
was kann ich sein
[Musik]
eine drohne
ich glaube ich habe das gar nicht
gesehen weil meine fans kempter
vorläufig zeigt sich jetzt noch mal ohne
das sehe ich wirklich schwarz für ihn
ist wird sich weil er heißt schwach wie
glücklich sind ein paar menschen wie
habt ihr diese rekorde einfach geplant
kann ich einen salto üben mit meinem
motorrad oft einen extrem ag
wenn ich das gewesen wäre hätten mich
beide autos getroffen und eine drohne
werden wir auf kopf gefallen von oben
unten war irgendwie
[Musik]
die ist absolut nichts passiert weil sie
zum glück da auf die darüber dass da ist
also stabhochsprung und normaler respekt
an alle die das machen ich konnte mir
das nicht vorstellen ich hab schon früh
dabei normal im hochsprung hat schon
angst alte ab jetzt macht sie in den
zweiten versuchen das war in nationaler
rekord anscheinend und dass nate sich
was ich hätte danach nie wieder so eine
paul stange an gefassten aus sechs
schulen da fand was da von allen bewusst
deutschland ist daran gefallen ich habe
sowas hier angucken wer jetzt im
wohnheim kommt oder so mein gott oh mein
gott oh mein gott wie würdet ihr
reagieren alter wie würdet ihr reagieren
wenn ihr schwimmen würde unter werden
alt gewesen wäre dann wäre das anders
ausgegangen
von diesen geschwindigkeiten wird
ich überlege gerade wenn ich formel 1
fahrer wäre ich der taube ausgewichen
wäre aber dann
ich hätte da wahrscheinlich mehr gesehen
wenn ich damit 300 km h drauf zu
gefahren mit sich so viele bäume was was
das sind zwillinge aus deutschland sogar
[Musik]
junge bei 0,001 sekunden
hab ich schon mal gesehen da wird doch
eingestellt weil der boden hat einfach
einer gewartet die größten tags alter
warten vom ziel und sind dann so oft
einfach junge darüber lockt
[Musik]
das ist der grund warum ich niemals so
was machen würde oder bungee jumping
dinner in dein leben hängt an einem
karabiner warum macht man das adrenalin
einholten adrenalin woanders und nicht
an der luft oder die lieben zum sei denn
leute macht das nicht er ist von seinem
koma aufgewacht hat sondern rubbellos
gezogen und hat einfach ein auto
gewonnen
das krasseste was ich mal bei so so robl
glücks aktionen hatte war bei mcdonald's
die pommes und eis
ja das war ein ganz ganz glückliche
leute meine lieben freunde was war eure
glücklichste situation im kompletten
leben ich glaube bei mir
[Musik]